my lords and members of the house of
commons
my government's priority is to deliver a
national recovery from the pandemic
that makes the united kingdom stronger
healthier
and more prosperous than before
to achieve this my government will level
up opportunities across all parts of the
united kingdom
supporting jobs businesses and economic
growth
and addressing the impact of the
pandemic on public services
my government will protect the health of
the nation
continuing the vaccination program and
providing
additional funding to support the nhs
my ministers will bring forward
legislation
to empower the nhs to innovate and
embrace technology
patients will receive more tailored and
preventative care
closer to home measures will be brought
forward
to support the health and well-being of
the nation
including to tackle obesity and improve
mental health
proposals on social care reform will be
brought
forward my government will build on the
success of the vaccination program
to lead the world in life sciences
pioneering new treatments against
diseases like
cancer and securing jobs and investment
across the country
my ministers will oversee the fastest
ever increase in public funding
for research and development and pass
legislation
to establish an advanced research agency
following the unprecedented support
provided to businesses during the
pandemic
proposals will be brought forward to
create
and support jobs and improve regulation
my government will strengthen the
economic ties across the union
investing in and improving national
infrastructure
proposals will be taken forward to
transform
connectivity by rail and bus and to
extend
5g mobile coverage and gigabit
capable broadband
legislation will support a lifetime
skills guarantee
to enable flexible access to high
quality education and training
throughout people's lives
measures will be introduced to ensure
that support for businesses
reflects the united kingdom's strategic
interests
and drives economic growth
laws will simplify procurement in the
public session
sector eight new freeports will create
hubs for trade and help regenerate
communities
my government will ensure that the
public finances
are returned to a sustainable path once
the economic recovery
is secure
measures will be brought forward to
ensure that children have the best start
in life
prioritizing their early years
my ministers will address lost learning
during the pandemic
and ensure every child has a high
quality education
and is able to fulfill their potential
my government will help more people to
own their own home
while enhancing the rights of those who
rent
laws to modernize the planning system so
that more homes can be built
will be brought forward along with
measures to end the practice of ground
rents for new
leasehold properties my ministers will
establish in law
a new building safety regulator to
ensure that the tragedies of the past
are never repeated
measures will be brought forward to
address racial and ethnic disparities
and ban conversion therapy
legislation will support the voluntary
sector
by reducing unnecessary bureaucracy
and releasing additional funds for good
causes
my government will create invest in new
green industries to create jobs
while protecting the environment
the united kingdom is committed to
achieving net zero greenhouse gas
emissions
by 2050 and will continue to lead the
way
internationally by hosting the cop26
summit in glasgow
legislation will set binding
environmental targets
legislation will also be brought forward
to ensure the united kingdom has
and promotes the highest standards of
animal welfare
my government will strengthen and renew
democracy
and the constitution legislation will be
introduced
to ensure the integrity of elections
protect freedom of speech and restore
the balance of power
between the executive legislature
and the courts my ministers will promote
the strength and integrity of the union
measures will be brought forward to
strengthen devolved government
in northern ireland and address the
legacy of the past
my government will introduce measures to
increase the safety and security of its
citizens
legislation will increase sentences for
the most serious
and violent offenders and ensure the
timely administration of justice
proposals will be brought forward to
address violence
including against women and girls
and to support victims
measures will be brought forward to
establish a fairer immigration system
that strengthens the united kingdom's
borders
and deters criminals who facilitate
dangerous and illegal journeys
my government will lead the way in
ensuring internet safety for all
especially for children whilst
harnessing the benefits
of a free open and secure internet
my ministers will provide our gallant
armed services
with the biggest spending increase in 30
years
taking forward their program of
modernization
and reinforcing the united kingdom's
commitment
to nato my ministers will honor and
strengthen the armed forces covenant
placing it in law measures will be
introduced
to provide national insurance
contribution relief
for employers of veterans
legislation will be introduced to
counter hostile activity by foreign
states
my ministers will implement the
integrated review of security
defense development and foreign policy
the united kingdom will host the g7
summit
and lead the global effort to secure a
robust economic recovery from the
pandemic
my ministers will deepen trade ties in
the gulf
africa and the indo-pacific
my government will continue to provide
aid
where it has the greatest impact on
reducing poverty
and alleviating human suffering
my government will uphold human rights
and democracy across
the world it will take forward a global
effort
to get 40 million girls across the world
into school
members of the house of commons
estimates for the public services
will be laid before you
my lords and members of the house of
commons other measures will be laid
before you
i pray that the blessing of almighty god
may rest
upon your counsels